[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذلك لدينا حل للجزر
الصغيرة يمكننا جعلها مستدامة
آه جعلها أكثر استقلالية
عن الطاقة وتقليل تكلفة الطاقة ،
لذا فإن شركة السباحة المباعة هي شركة للطاقة الشمسية
تركز على الجزر الاستوائية الصغيرة ،
وسوقنا الرئيسي حاليًا هو
جزر المالديف لقد قمنا أيضًا ببعض المشاريع
في ماليزيا في إندونيسيا
لماذا نركز على الجزر الاستوائية الصغيرة
هناك أه سببين رئيسيين لذلك
أه رقم واحد أه الجزر الاستوائية لديها
الكثير من الشمس وهو ثابت جدًا
طوال العام
السبب الثاني  هو أن لديهم
تكاليف طاقة مرجعية عالية جدًا لأنه
في الجزر الصغيرة يتم إنتاج كل الطاقة
بمولدات الديزل وتكون
طاقة الديزل عادةً ما تكون بثلاثة إلى خمسة
أضعاف تكلفة الطاقة
التقليدية وبالطبع فإن طاقة الديزل أيضًا
غير مستدامة للغاية
[موسيقى]
لذا فإن الطاقة الشمسية هي من حيث المبدأ
حلاً جيدًا جدًا للجزر الاستوائية ،
ولكن عادة ما يكون لديك أحد
التحديات الخاصة وهو
هذا  تكون السرعة محدودة للغاية في الجزر ، وفي
بعض الأحيان يكون لديك بعض مساحات الأسطح التي
يمكن استخدامها ولكنها أيضًا ليست
مثالية دائمًا
، وبالتالي في معظم الجزر خاصة
في جزر المالديف مع أنظمة الطاقة الشمسية التقليدية
على الأسطح أو على الأرض ،
لا يمكنك استبدال أكثر من 10  15 من
استهلاك الديزل أه نحن في السباحة لذلك
لدينا الطموح
لتحويل إنتاج الطاقة في
الجزر الاستوائية وبالتالي تحتاج إلى
حل يمكن أن يحل محل ما لا يقل عن 50
إلى 60 في المائة من استهلاك الديزل
وإذا لم يكن هناك مساحة على  الجزر
ليس لديك سوى مكان واحد آخر للذهاب إليه
وهو البحر بشكل أساسي ،
لذلك توصلنا إلى حل شمسي عائم
للمحيط مقاوم للأمواج ومقاوم للتآكل
وأنظمة الكهروضوئية النموذجية العائمة
للبحيرات هي طوافات بلاستيكية بسيطة أه
هذا بالتأكيد  ليست الطريقة التي
تعمل بها تقنيتنا ، لذا فإن نظامنا الشمسي c
هو ما يسمى بهيكل إطار الفضاء
، وترتفع الألواح الشمسية
أكثر من مترين أب  فوق
سطح البحر ،
تكون البنية التحتية نفسها مفتوحة للغاية ، لذا
فهي تسمح للأمواج والرياح بالمرور
من خلال البنية التحتية ، مما
يقلل من القوى على النظام بأكمله
أيضًا على نظام الإرساء
والرسو ، وبالتالي فهو مصمم
لتحمل القوى القوية  يمكن أن يكون
في البحر
من أمواج الرياح من التيارات وما إلى
ذلك ، لذا فهو هيكل قوي جدًا ومتطور
ومصمم
للبقاء في البحر لمدة 25 إلى 30
عامًا على الأقل وتحمل الظروف
[موسيقى]